these coffee filters are made of 100%
cellulose fiber harvested from slow
growing pine and spruce trees in the
forests of southern scandinavia 30
percent of the paper cellulose content
is left over from earlier production the
other 70% is raw cellulose fiber the
materials go into a machine called a
popper which works like a giant food
processor a paper making machine spreads
a one-inch layer of Pulp across a wire
mesh belt the pulp forms a soggy sheet
of paper at the next station heavy
compression rollers squeeze almost half
the water out of the paper a tool
applies a crepe texture
next they use 38 steam-heated rollers to
dry the paper completely the roller
surface temperatures are around 250
degrees as the finished paper exits the
machine a camera registers the location
of holes dirt or other defects that have
to be cut out the paper is sliced into 2
foot rolls so it can fit in the filter
making machine sensors in the filter
making machine make sure the paper is
aligned correctly at the machines first
station tiny needles pierce holes in the
paper to enhance the quality of
filtration at the next station a stamp
imprints the company logo in the paper a
knife slices the paper in half a roller
embosses a seam connecting the two
layers of paper along the bottom inside
then a second roller cuts the conical
shape of the filter the machine produces
four thousand filters per minute the
next station cuts the filters apart and
collects the leftover paper which will
be recycled in DePaul
the filters are sent to an automatic
counting machine that divides them into
stacks of 80 the machine feeds the
stacks to the packaging line then it
opens the box with a vacuum and inserts
the filters if the machine sensor
detects a problem like filters in the
wrong position or missing filters it
ejects that box from the line how the
cellulose is processed in the pulper
determines how the filter will perform
the factory processes cellulose finally
to make filters designed to brew strong
coffee fine celos produces paper that
drains slowly keeping the water and
coffee beans together longer resulting
in a stronger flavor